ever wonder why the democrats don't stop
the crisis at our southern border
maybe it's because they want to turn
those immigrants into democratic votes
regardless of citizenship the new york
times is out with a new guest essay
arguing quote there is no good reason
you should have to be a citizen to vote
that's according to journalist atasa
oraxia abrahamian
she goes on to write it's time for
democrats to radically expand the
electorate
and she's not ashamed to admit democrats
are likely to be the biggest
beneficiaries
of this change here now to explain the
pitfalls
of voting without citizenship is stephen
miller
america first legal founder former
senior adviser to president trump
stephen
uh this just seems to be like oh let's
just skip all those other steps we're
pretending
we're going to import voters and make
them citizens let's just forget that
part they don't have time for that do
they
the new york times opinion piece is
extraordinarily revealing for the
mindset of the left
which is they want to erode and
ultimately erase the very idea
of american citizenship voting is not
just a right it's also a responsibility
you have to learn our country's history
its culture
its language its values to be able to
make an informed decision about voting
that's why this country has a
naturalization
process a lawful process to go through
to learn who we are and what we're about
and one of the things that we did during
the trump administration
that's actually been reversed by
president biden was we actually
improved and upgraded the naturalization
process to put a greater emphasis
on american history and american values
you know what's interesting is that
part of becoming an american and you see
this with people as they're sworn in
is is that commitment is people come
here not because the weather is great
it's because they want to become an
american there is a
transition that happens it's almost like
in your dna
there's the freedom becomes palpable and
clear
if if that's if we can if we're going to
erase that
then effectively there is no country
there's no sovereignty there is no
america
within which to become a part of is
there which is the entire
goal you know when susan rice who is
currently the head of the domestic
policy council
which means she's responsible for
overseeing immigration policy in the
united states
when she says as she did a few days ago
that dreamers are americans
she's engaged in purposeful lying
and she's engaged in an attack on the
english language
americans are americans citizens
are citizens and dreamers so-called are
illegal immigrants
and when we deprive people of this
country of their language of their
ability to be able to speak clearly and
to say no
if you come here illegally you are not a
citizen you are not an american
you do not have the right to vote in our
elections you don't have the right
to occupy an american job these are not
controversial thoughts
these are basic fundamental ideas to
what it means to have
and to keep a nation well see this be
we're a nation that's based on an
idea and it makes it as a result easier
to kind of squash that idea
with changing the language making the
most one of the most important rights
the right to vote as a citizen that's
the thing that we have
and in the meantime i know that you've i
believe just filed a lawsuit
uh through your foundation your legal
foundation
that deals with the race-based support
for farmers what's that about
well i'm proud to discuss this
exclusively tonight with you and your
viewing audience
hot off the presses we have just filed a
brand new lawsuit
against the administration and it has to
do with this very idea of what it means
to be a citizen that we're talking about
being a citizen in this country means
you get treated equally
the sba administrator small business
administration
the head of the sba unlawfully and
unconstitutionally
deprived american restaurant owners of
their right to access relief funds
because
of their race depriving them of their
rights as citizens
with this racial preferences scheme now
we beat that in court
but here's the problem many many many
american restaurant owners
never got their loans before we won that
court ruling
so we are suing her we are suing
administrator
guzman in her personal capacity under
long-standing supreme court precedent
that says if you violate someone's
constitutional rights
even if you're a government officer you
could be held personally accountable wow
so we are asking the court to make her
great pay damages to these americans
were fighting back and any restaurant
owner who filed in that lawful window
and was deprived join our lawsuit and we
are going to establish in this country a
principle for every biden staffer
you break someone's rights you violate
your constitutional oath
there will be legal consequences
excellent and where what's your website
so people know how to reach out to you
quickly aflegal.org that's aflegal.org
perfect thank you great great job and
thank you very much for sharing it with
us now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else